Secretary of State Mike Pompeo joins me
live tonight from the State Department
mr. secretary thanks for joining us
Brad it's great to be with you you heard
the set up there by rich we know what
you said today about how important this
moment is and that nobody should be
surprised by it however there are some
people inside the Pentagon we're told
senior military leaders and Pentagon
officials who are surprised by it a
little bit and perhaps they have
objections to it fearful that it could
mean harm to US troops for example in
Iraq your response to that Brett we just
we just call the reality of what it is
the IRGC is a terrorist organization
we've now designated them we're always
doing everything we can to make sure we
protect every American soldier
everywhere but the fact is the IRGC has
already killed over 600 American
soldiers so you can't have peace you
can't have stability you can't have
security in the Middle East without
weakening the Islamic Revolutionary
Guard Corps that's what our sanctions
today were aimed at doing and we're
confident this increased pressure will
save American lives and create more
stability more peace more security
throughout the Middle East you know that
the Iraqi Shia forces the militias there
are tight with the Iraqi army US troops
obviously work with both of them frankly
how will they distinguish and this will
this become a complicated problem on the
ground Brett it was a complicated
problem when Barack Obama entered into a
disastrous nuclear deal you've not been
talking about Iran since I was a member
of Congress and then we had a long
conversation when I was the director of
the CIA so it was complicated long
before this morning's announcement what
we're trying to do is reduce that
complexity take down this malign
activity that the kleptocrats the
clerical crept kleptocrats in an Iran
are engaged in to change their behavior
in such a fundamental way that we can be
safe all across the world and certainly
in Iraq and in the Middle East the head
of the IRGC this man Qasem Soleimani
is by all accounts a bad character and
has led all kinds of attacks but are you
saying
that he now is equated to let's say the
head of Isis al Baghdady in US policy
perspective yeah
he is terrorist so we as a country have
a policy to target hem war capture him
Qasem Soleimani has the blood of
Americans on his hands Brett as does the
force that he leads and America is
determined each time we find an
organization institution or an
individual that has taken the lives of
Americans it is our responsibility it's
indeed president Trump's duty and we
have made tremendous progress in this
administration's first two years to
reduce the risk that any American will
be killed by Qasem Soleimani and his
merrie Brandon brothers ever again
critics including the Iranians say this
move had more to do with the Israeli
election tomorrow than it did with US
policy toward Iran your response we've
been working on this a long time which I
personally been working on this a long
time it took a lot of work to make sure
that we had all the facts right we had
everybody in the United States
government in the right place so that we
could announce this it happened today
because today was the day we were ready
to make the announcement all right I
want to talk about Libya quickly another
move by a general their haft are
launching an offensive on Tripoli your
sense of the situation in Libya and
could there be sanctions heading that
way too you know we've watched the the
movement of half guard has militias in
and around Tripoli now into the southern
part of Tripoli we've urged after we've
urged all the parties there to solve
this to solve their dispute through a
political process we we think that's the
only way that this can be resolved this
this won't be resolved through a force
of arms there's just no way that's going
to take place we there's a UN process
we've been part of that general Huff tar
has been part of that week we urge
General have started I stand down move
back to the negotiating table so that we
can get a political resolution Libby you
know Brett the history of Libya
you know the fractured nature of the
place and absent a political resolution
I will continue to have fighting will
continue to have chaos and they'll
continue to be arrests to the United
States of America for
Isis they're from other terrorists it's
not in America's best interest and so
we're urging all of the parties to
re-engage in conversation so that we get
a political resolution or turn to
Venezuela bouncing around here will
there be more efforts against the Cuban
government for supporting the Venezuelan
Maduro regime that seems to be not
budging
despite actions from the US and around
the world you know Brett it's the Cubans
that are providing the security for
Maduro that's got to be embarrassing if
you're a Venezuelan general but apart
from that the Cubans need to understand
that Maduro is a lost cause it's not
going to happen his days are numbered
they need to get on the right side of
history they need to leave Venezuela and
we will continue to do all we can to
encourage the Cubans to take onboard
that understanding stop supporting
Maduro and allow the Venezuelan people
to have the democracy that they so
richly deserve the secretary we heard
from the Obama administration that
bashar al-assad's days were numbered but
we just didn't know the number he's
still there we're hearing that
Venezuelans not recognize leadership
days are numbered too what do you put
the number at yeah I don't have a number
for you Brett
but suffice it to say we we know that
the Venezuelan people will ultimately
demand these two situations are very
different I might add
Bashir Assad controls a small fraction
of Syria today the work that the Trump
administration has done to deny Assad
the capacity to rebuild his nation this
is a guy who believes he won but the
truth is the Middle East is in a much
more stable much better place today than
it was when President Obama was running
the joint in Syria he left the Syrian
people in a bad place millions of
displaced persons and our efforts to
take down the Caliphate to create an
opportunity and a political process in
Syria are yielding real results in Syria
back to Cuba for a second is the major
league baseball move today more effort
to pinch Cuba yep okay cut and dry yes
it is
yeah bread look there but it's very
important we got that part right
it's very important we get that part
right the Cubans are the the folks who
are providing the support along now with
the Russians in Venezuela we're gonna do
everything we can to pull pull them out
pull them apart so the Venezuelan people
can have what they deserve two more
quick things since over the weekend the
Homeland Security Secretary has now
resigned Kirsten Nielsen there have been
more cabinet shake-up moves people
leaving the administration than in any
administration since Woodrow Wilson your
sense about the people moving in and out
of this administration and what that
means to somebody sitting at home I'm
not sure about your data Brad I had a
chance to speak with secretary Nielsen
today I wish her well this mission down
at the border is incredibly important
I've got to make sure we have the laws
right I urge every member of Congress to
help us fix it so that we can do what
the American people are demanding regain
American sovereignty along our southern
border and solve both the security and
humanitarian crisis that exists along
our southern border do you think that
the family separation such policy is
going to change along the border
you know I'll leave that to the
Department of Homeland Security to
respond to questions like that our old
State Department's role has been to work
with elements in El Salvador the
Honduras and Guatemala and in Mexico
with those governments so that they can
better secure their borders and keep
individuals from making this trek up and
through Mexico which is very dangerous
and resulting in real risk here in the
United States as well I'd be remiss if I
didn't ask you these last two things
have you ruled out running for Senate in
Kansas in 2020 I have have you ruled out
running for governor in Kansas in 2022
that's given the two seconds thought
okay mr. secretary we appreciate your
time thank you very far